この部屋に引っ越したんですけれども
なんか空調！空気清浄機みたいなのあるものの
めっちゃ暑いんですよ！！！！！！超暑い！！
それにエアコンもないしー、実はすごい過酷な中で
動画を撮っております。はじめしゃちょーです。
もう、今も暑いんだけどもー
結局！！人ってのは！！！
と思うんですよー。僕もそうだし、君もそうでしょ。（キメ顔✨）
人というのは汗をかきたくない生き物なんですよ
なぜかというと！
なんかこう、臭いとか汚いとか、汗のアレがつくと
イヤじゃないですか！！！！（小並感）
そりゃイヤですよ。
それはきっと男も女もイヤだと思うんですけれども
結局汗はやっぱ人なんで
かくのは仕方ないんですけれども
やっぱバレるのがイヤなんで、
結局ね、バレなかったらいいと思うんですよ
汗をかいても
誰かにこう、「うわぁ、汗かいてる」
って思われるのがイヤなんで
ちょっと今回はですね、検証で
っていう検証をちょっとしていこうと思います
でまあ、僕も人間なんで、汗の量を
コントロールできないんで
まあちょっと、なんとかして汗をたらそうと思います
たぶんこれでだいたい何リットルくらいの汗を
かいていいかが たぶん目安として
わかりやすいと思うので
今回の検証でみなさんが
かいていい汗の量が決まりますので
参考にこれから汗をかいてください
よしー
ﾌﾟｯﾎﾟﾎﾟｰﾝﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯ
ﾌﾟｯﾎﾟﾎﾟｰﾝﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯﾎ ｯﾎﾟ    ｯﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯﾎﾟﾎﾟﾎﾟﾎﾟｰﾝ
ﾌﾟｯﾎﾟﾎﾟｰﾝﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍ ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯﾝ
ﾌﾟｯﾎﾟﾎﾟｰﾝﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯ
ﾌﾟｯﾎﾟﾎﾟｰﾝﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯﾎﾟｯ        ﾎﾟｯ       ﾎﾟﾝ
ﾄﾞｩｸｯﾄﾞｩｸｯﾄﾞｩｸｯ（心臓の音）
ｹﾞｪﾎｯ（咳）
た：シフトB押しちゃったら、なんか出てきた。
は：シフトB・・・あ、これ？
た：うん
は：これはこのままで速度があるから
速度が出てるだけで、@%&*`¥カスタムで何%かで
４００っていったら４倍速になるっていう
た：あ、ありがとう　あれ？？（ガン見）
ﾍﾟﾍﾟｯ  ﾍﾟｯﾍﾟｯ   ﾍﾟﾍﾟｯﾍﾟｯﾍﾟﾍﾟ
ﾋﾟﾋﾟｰﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟｰ
ﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟｰ
ﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟｰﾋﾟ
ﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟｰﾌﾟｰﾌﾟｰﾌﾟﾌﾟ
ﾌﾟｰﾌﾟﾌﾟｰ     ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟｰﾍﾟﾍﾟﾌﾟ
ﾌﾟﾌﾟｯﾌﾟｯﾌﾟﾌﾟ
✨✨ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟｯ✨✨